We need to factor negative 4t
squared minus 12t minus 9.
And a good place to start is
to say, well, are there any
common factors for all
of these terms?
When you look at them, well
these first two are divisible
by 4, these last 2 are divisible
by 3, but not all of
them are divisible
any one number.
Will, but you could factor out
a negative 1, but even if you
factor out a negative 1-- so you
say this is the same thing
as negative 1, times positive
4t squared plus 12t plus 9--
you still end up with a non-one
coefficient out here
and on the second degree term,
on the t squared term.
So you might want
to immediately
start grouping this.
And if you did factor it by
grouping, it would work, you
would get the right answer.
But there is something about
this equation that might pop
out at you that might make it a
little bit simpler to solve.
And to understand that, let's
take a little bit of a break
here on the right hand side,
and just think about what
happens if you take a plus b
times a plus b, if you just
have a binomial squared.
Well you have a times a,
which is a squared.
Then you have a times that
b, which is plus ab.
Then you have b times a, which
is the same thing is ab.
And then you have b times b,
or you have b squared.
And so if you add these middle
two terms, right here, you're
left with a squared plus
2ab plus b squared.
This is the square
of a binomial.
Now, does this right here, does
4t squared plus 12t plus
9 fit this pattern?
Well the 4t squared
is a squared.
So this right here
If that is a squared right
there, then what
does a have to be?
If this is a squared, then a
would be equal to the square
root of this.
It would be 2t.
And if this is b squared,
let me do that
in a different color.
If this right here is b
squared, if the 9 is b
squared, right there,
then that means that
b is equal to 3.
It's equal to the positive
square root of the 9.
Now, this number, right here--
and actually it doesn't have
to just be equal to 3,
it might have been
negative 3 as well.
It could be plus or minus 3.
But this number here,
is it 2 times ab?
Right?
That's the middle term
that we care about.
Is it 2 times ab?
Well if we multiply 2t
times 3, we get 6t.
And then if we multiply that
times 2, you get 12t.
This right here, 12t, is equal
to 2 times 2t times 3.
It is 2 times ab.
And if this was a negative 3,
we would look to see if this
was a negative 12, but this
does work for positive 3.
So this it does fit the pattern
of a perfect square.
This is a square
of a binomial.
So if you wanted to factor
this-- the stuff on the
inside, you still have that
negative 1 out there, the 4t
squared plus 12t plus 9-- you
could immediately say, well
that's going to be a plus
b times a plus b.
Or 2t plus 3 times 2t plus 3, or
you could just say, it's 2t
plus 3 squared.
It fits this pattern.
And, of course, you can't
forget about this
negative 1 out here.
You could have also solved it by
grouping, but this might be
a quicker thing to recognize.
This is a number squared.
That's another number squared.
If you take each of those
numbers that you're squaring,
take their product and multiply
it by 2, you have
that right there.
So this is a perfect square.